attends ça là cela ça valait folle
durant son adolescence cyril a laissé un
très mauvais souvenir au grand
schtroumpf à te souviens à l'école non
mais grand schtroumpf
c'est un prof quand je trouve moi c'est
cette approche on prouve que monsieur
cochet quoi mais ce projet et j'ai été
surprise pour toi
il est temps il est vrai il lui a fait
la misère cirilli lui a fait une misère
pas possible d'empêcher la torre
monsieur cochet temps et moi je l'aimé
ouais franchement tu aimais reprocher
s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
les dossiers sur lui je sais pas si vous
avez des dossiers ce n'est pas trop
méchant moi j'm'en ouais mais c'est trop
fort si tu te souviens que quand tu te
mettais des ti jogging saoul trente sept
ans jean c'est vrai je mettais des
joggings somme où jean remplumer un
petit peu ouais c'est vrai tu l'aimé
bien quand même nationalité mais bien
été mais bien c'est vrai que je suis un
coach
disons que tu faisais partie de ces
élèves qui étaient un peu des cancres
mais on t'aimait bien et tout le monde
tu aimais bien passée c'était un futé
non mais regardez ça ça je reconnais pas
je reconnais pas de se poser la retraite
c'est normal je veux enfin je vous
reconnais pas monsieur popularité
toujours avec lord derniers mois des
amis à moi
bayard sa vie de bouaziz ouais c'est
vrai il y avait des arts
ouais ouais y avait john atteint ouais
c'est vrai alors oui et puis on avait
plein de est-ce que j'ai déjà triché en
classe alors moi hein mon avis tu
triches m étais tu es tellement malin
que j'ai jamais réussi à rattraper
c'est vrai hahaha com ont déjà attrapé
une fois non moi personnellement je suis
maire je reconnais parti avait tellement
des notes qui était en dents de scie en
mathématiques un jour c'était bonjour
c'était pas bon que moi je suis sûr que
qu'est ce que moi je me suis fait
attraper une fois donc on voit si c'est
vous donc là serait dès lors pas en
classe ah ah ouais alors là alors celle
là oui tout le monde s'en souvient
il m'a à l'économat soldés par deux
champions
[Applaudissements]
amiens
pourquoi